and you know you'll need to provide
multiple copies of this image so low
pixel count devices can save bandwidth
while high pixel count devices can get a
crisp image
it's possible to do this on the server
side in some cases in fact some content
systems let you simply specify what size
you want a given source image at and
they deal with the transcoding on the
server end including caching if you want
the images to actually represent
different art different crops for
example you'll have to do that manually
for each of these images though you
should remember to tune the quality
parameters to minimize file size while
maximizing quality you'll need at least
1x and 2x versions of your images
although 1.3x and 3x are fairly common
too now again note that although i'm
speaking of this as 1x or 2x for
purposes of device pixel ratio
for responsive images you may request
different images based on available
layout width you may even want to change
the image itself for example in
landscape mode i may want to crop the
picture completely differently